[Musik]
ich finde es gibt dinge über die müssen
wir reden im schulsystem keine frage
aber im großen und ganzen denke ich
laufen viele dinge auch wirklich richtig
gut bei uns im schulsystem
[Musik]
ich bin ein großer fan vom notensystem
ich glaube eine direkte rückmeldung über
leistung und linguist und sind ganz ganz
wichtig und ich bin auch der meinung in
den letzten jahren sind wir zunehmend
dazu gekommen dass wir so schlecht
leistungen irgendwie so klein reden ich
finde das gar nicht schlimm warum darf
man junge menschen nicht sagen hey das
hast du nicht gut gemacht das musst du
möglicherweise auch mal machen
[Musik]
also ich glaube das muss man wirklich
absolut individuell betrachten also
natürlich ist unser job das ist mir zu
vermitteln was in unseren schulen
eigenen arbeitsplänen dann gibt in kuba
steht natürlich das ist unser aber ich
sag mal als selbstverständlich kümmern
wir uns unsere schüler und wenn es eben
aktuelle belange geht dann kümmern wir
uns zuerst um die schüler die schule
bereit bestimmt nicht auf alles im leben
vor
aber das ziel aus meiner sicht auch
nicht wenn man in der schule lernt wie
man sich ein problem stellt wie man da
herangeht ich glaube dann kann man auch
die aufgabe die nach gästen gekommen
meister